it's a question I hear getting thrown
around a lot these days which is better
the show or the movie and really it's a
unique situation to be in up until 2013
Dragonball had never released a movie
that was in any way tied to the main
series plot the main series being the
storied events of the manga written by
creator Akira Toriyama or the Canon as
some people called it in the movies we
had characters like Lord slug genelva
Rolly and so forth being in the movies
however meant that these characters were
not part of the main story they were not
Canon characters they were fun what-if
scenarios fan fictions brought to light
for the sake of a featured film they in
no way impacted the main series at all
but here today we are going to discuss
the first-ever Canon Dragon Ball movie
and compared to its animes retelling
this is anime movie Dragon Ball super
versus battle of gods in 1995 the Dragon
Ball manga penned by Akira Toriyama came
to a close and seeing as the anime
depend on the manga for the story the
Dragon Ball Z series ended on January
31st 1996 and a great series came to an
abrupt and unsatisfying it until on
March 30th 2013 after 17 years the new
Dragon Ball content from a curatorial
was finally released it wasn't a manga
it wasn't an anime it was a movie and
because accurate Auriemma wrote it it
was no the first-ever canon movie for
Dragon Ball which was huge and went on
to have great commercial success another
two years passed by and in 2015 the
announcement of Dragon Ball super was
made a new Dragon Ball anime following
the events of Dragon Ball Z's majin buu
work now the problem with that was the
battle of gods movie in 2013 had already
told that story and now the series
wanted to recount that story over the
course of 14 episodes causing a divide
as well as confusion amongst fans
ultimately leading to the question which
should I watch which is better I'm here
to help answer that question today in
five rounds representing various
categories I'll compare these two
incarnations of the same story to help
you decide once and for all
which is better round 1 animation when
it comes to any anime few things are as
important as the quality of its
animation those that have come from
Dragon Ball Z's heyday can confirm
while the series had its bad moments
when the chips were down that show
delivered in a big way but it was never
something people thought about
complimenting or drawing attention to
back then it was just another great show
on TV now thanks to the Internet as soon
as an episode airs you can literally get
hundreds of thousands of responses and
opinions on that episode in seconds
which by and large is a great thing but
it can lead to a sheep-like mentality
when it comes to some people forming
their own opinions which can then lead
to unfair and uninformed criticisms that
said I haven't exactly been quiet when
it comes to voicing my own opinions on
the subject either I've made videos both
criticizing the bad and praising the
good of this art but I haven't really
thrown my two cents in and what I
thought of the movies animation when
compared with the series and there's two
big reasons for that time and money when
toy animation is tasked with creating a
weekly episode of Dragon Ball super they
have to make magic happen between
organizing storyboard artists script
writers digital coloring key animators
in-between animators voice actors
directors producers touch-up artists and
that's not even the half of it it's a
miracle they even have any good
animation to show at all
each episode requiring thousands and
thousands of drawings and that's where
time comes in the mark of a true master
illustrator isn't how good the work is
but how fast he can reduce quality work
take this for example this is a drawing
of Goku I'm working on right now it has
taken me quite a few hours to get to
this point but if I was to work for Toey
animation I would need to produce a
drawing every 10 minutes or less
depending on my position in the team
this is a Goku that I drew in 10 minutes
but why is this relevant well the movie
was in production for well over a year
that means the artists the toy animation
had time to draw without those pesky
restraints they were free to take their
time which is the ideal scenario but
that's not to say toey doesn't have some
great in-house animators and surely they
could get some outside help for more
experienced master illustrators and
animators right well you're correct all
that is true but that's when money comes
in those pretty pictures that dance
across our screens cost a fortune to
produce if there are to be any good at
all and with the limited budget that OE
is working with to produce this series
they have to spread out the best
animators as efficiently as possible
episode 5 is a great example of an
episode that had its moments but
crumbled to time and budget restraints
it was directed by the exceedingly
talented Naoki Tata
but failed to deliver anything
substantial because the budget in time
wasn't there to make the episode for the
movie however in addition to their
existing budget to help fund the
production and the promotion for the
movie Toei animation was granted 50
million yen as part of a nonprofit
organization uni Japanese co-production
certification program which was
developed by the Japanese government
yeah you heard rice
the Japanese government helped funding a
Dragonball movie the movie did you see
GI which ultimately took from the
experience in my opinion but even though
the use of CGI is jarring after 291
episodes of Dragon Ball Z I challenge
any of you to find a single scene that
stands up to this masterpiece from the
movie in terms of animation and even
though I am proud of what the young
animation teams at oi have produced with
super there is no denying who the real
juggernaut in this category is when it
goes to the movie round 2 supporting
cast who this next category is a doozy
without these guys the movie in series
would fall apart they are the glue that
holds it all together the Bill Murray 2
Goku's Michael Jordan and although they
are in fact the same characters slight
differences in direction and exposition
divide them so now it's time to decide
which had the best supporting cast
looking from the outside I saw these two
casts as mirror images of one another
every character was accounted for and
they even shared some of the same
dialogue we explaining Goku's pass with
freezer beer is cracking that joke about
the length of an anime episode I've gone
through these with fine tooth combs and
really beat for beat they hit the same
notes or do that in the movie when the
cheetah meets beerus on screen for the
first time we are presented with a
flashback it takes us back to the
Saiyans homeworld where the cheetahs
father the king is hosting lord beerus
for dinner King Vegeta acting as the
footstool while the Prince watches from
afar it's a very nice scene showing how
even the most prized film was been to be
races will however in this series it
adds this extra dynamic to the city that
in my opinion makes it much more
compelling we again get greeted with a
flashback much like in the movie
complete with Vegeta footstool the key
difference being the young prince's
reaction to his father in pain instead
of staring fighting his calm he runs to
his father's aid only to be paralyzed
with fear he falls to the floor and the
flashback suddenly ends the anime
version does
is much more in keeping with the
Cheetahs character and that's not even
the most important difference as the
interaction with Vegeta and beerus
continues the cheetah again falls to the
floor acting the encounter that he had
in his youth with lord beerus still
crippled by that same fear it adds a
gravity to the situation it creates an
extra obstacle for vegeta to overcome
and when he eventually does it's all the
more epic because we know what he went
through to get to that point
it connects his past to the present in a
much more visceral way and helps
validate beerus as an antagonist as a
result there is more detail and
substance in the animes retelling and
that's its biggest strength in the movie
beerus wakes and immediately goes in
search of the Super Saiyan God in the
anime we actually get to see beerus
traveling the universe acting as the god
of destruction and it seems such we
learn about his character through his
actions and not just as words that small
change to Vegeta see the introduction to
beerus his character and how lys engages
with vegeta and the others during the
fight scene all help paint a much more
interesting picture overall it's the
subtle changes that make the world of
difference point ghosts the anime round
3 beste goku okay that last one was the
supporting cast surely the movie with
the budget and time given to writing the
script has the most accurate main
character representation or do you think
the anime has the best leading man
portrayal whatever way you slice it
he's the Bill Murray to Dragon Balls
Groundhog Day it's time to decide which
one had the best son Goku
he's been the main character since
Dragon Ball Episode one with nearly 500
episodes to his name Goku has been the
head honcho throughout Dragon Ball
Dragon Ball Z and currently Dragon Ball
super and looking at this with so broad
of a spectrum I almost went insane
considering all the variables but at his
core Goku is cheerful tenacious and
naive with a strong urge to fight and
throw caution to the wind to satisfy
that itch we first get introduced to the
movies Goku WA his training of King
Kai's world really it's the perfect
scene to take up from and on top of that
he's arrogant than challenging lord
beerus to a fight from the get-go
naturally you think this must be our
perfect Goku but that's where the
similarities end
or go who loves to fight all-out he
craves a great fight more he rarely ever
begins a fight at full strength he
always in some small way works up to it
testing his opponent's strength to see
if he can push himself but in the movie
he
all out from the beginning forgetting to
save her the fight you can make the
argument that a chorus coker would go
all-out against lord beerus he's the god
of destruction the most dangerous entity
in the universe but remember once upon a
time when a certain tyrannical
intergalactic emperor squared off with
our hero even though the fate of the
entire universe was at stake
he still eased his way into the fight
saving his trump card for later in the
confrontation and that's where the anime
got it right Goku would of course go
through all the incarnations of Super
Saiyan until ultimately failing at Super
Saiyan 3 it just makes more sense with
his personality and his character now I
know he offered to go back down to Super
Saiyan 2 in the movie but there's a
certain amount of theater to Goku he
doesn't want to show his hand unless the
perfect moment the Goku vs. hit fight
from the universe six ark is testament
to that also I think the anime left more
room for characterization in the fight
sequences most notably being the episode
where go ku synchronized punches with
beerus began tearing the universe apart
fully aware of what is happening he
clashes fists beerus twice before
perfecting it on the third by the way if
he didn't master that movement by the
third the earth would have be destroyed
along with many other parts of the
universe goku just unflinchingly went
for it instead of playing it safe for
the sake of other safety even I have to
admit when I watched us for the first
time I exclaimed that such a Goku thing
to do so while the movie had some great
Goku moments none were as potent as what
the anime offered point goes to the
anime round for background and
environment from the rolling blue hills
and green skies of nanak to the desolate
wasteland as a pilot
Dragon Ball has showcased numerous
environments with some more memorable
than others it's time we compare the
best backgrounds and environments
possibly the most striking difference
between the movie and the anime is
retelling this choice of environment
they both take place during bullies 30th
birthday party and hit all the same key
plot points throughout but the locations
at which all these events take place
different tremendously the movie is set
at the brief family estate surrounded by
a bustling metropolis while the anime
opted for a nautical theme set on a
giant yacht in the midst of a giant blue
ocean if you're looking at this from a
functional perspective it really
shouldn't matter what the setting is
however when you start to look at it
from an animation standpoint it becomes
very clear why the
went for an all ocean backdrop it's
cheaper and it's easier to animate over
Toey just needs to accumulate stock
images and backgrounds of the ocean for
this section of the anime and just draw
the characters over it far less legwork
really it's actually really clever if
you think about it with the movie they
needed to get backgrounds for towns
cities forests oceans space clouds the
list goes on and as a result the movie
is much more visually stimulating this
is just a situation where the movie
offered everything the anime did and
much much more
when it comes to the overall setting the
anime is a fish out of water point goes
to the movie final round story I'm sorry
what was that again I'm a God your God
I'm a God not the guy I don't think in
my opinion this is by far the most
important aspect of any movie or TV show
while animation and faithful portrayals
of characters are very important
the story is paramount and for two very
similar tellings of the same story they
begin in two very different places but
how can you tell if one story is
superior is telling over another
especially when on the surface they are
almost identical well to answer that we
to ask ourselves a question what's our
favorite arc from Dragon Ball Z of the
four made arcs nine times out of 10
people will either choose the cell or
the free cycle and I think there's good
reason for that what these two arcs have
in common over the others is actually
quite simple but it makes sense it's not
their villains
it's not cool transformations or amazing
moves no it's long-term storytelling and
the very best example I could think of
for that is Gohan at the beginning of
Dragon Ball Z we met a tiny timid easily
scared young child hiding behind Goku's
leg suddenly and without warning he
demonstrated incredible feats of
strength that vanish in an instant and
these take place over the course of 185
episodes until that incredible scene
shows us exactly what we've been waiting
for Gohan's transformation into a Super
Saiyan 2 was a favorite of most fans
because it had been a part of the story
for years prior we had grown up with
this character it had gone on a journey
with him and a climax at that arm but
how does this apply to the current
argument between battle of gods to movie
and the Dragon Ball super anime well as
I said earlier they are two very similar
tellings
the same story but they began two very
different places in the anime we first
see beerus when he's attending dinner or
a planet he suspects of having delicious
food as a result of subpar cuisines
however beerus destroys half of the
entire planet
thus grabbing the attention of the old
and Supreme Kai this leads to beerus
seeking out the Super Saiyan God and
ultimately his fighter Goku begins and
like any fight worth talking about
it didn't just begin and end it had
sections or chapters if you will the
best way I can describe this is by
referring you to the Goku and Frieza
fight from Dragon Ball Z whenever
someone talks about that fight they need
to specify a specific part of it
be it the under water Kamehameha the
times xx kaio-ken prisons death the
Super Saiyan transformation Frieza
getting cut in half go whose mercy
freezes death believe it or not I
skipped a ton of things from that fight
my point is that they are all
self-contained stories within a greater
narrative they were smaller battles
within a war the Goku beerus fight is no
different it begins with the
transformation it has Goku coming to
terms with his power and new abilities
Goku trying to land a clean shot and
beerus beerus and go who's hand clashes
go to chess getting stabbed and so on
all of these help build the story to a
final conclusion that is both thrilling
and satisfied the viewer we see beerus
early in this series and learn how he
operates by seeing him worked as a guard
destruction we begin to understand
weaves as a character more and the role
he plays in all of this the movie
however doesn't demonstrate bears as a
threat prior to his interaction with
goku it doesn't show him acting as a god
of destruction it has a fight that while
incredible is made of two parts and is a
self-contained fight sequence with no
interim micro stories the core issue is
that one of the movie's provides a much
more rich animation visual experience it
delivers a shallow representation of
what Dragon Ball fans have come to
appreciate and in reality it never some
chance with the extended runtime at 105
minutes compared to the animes 252
minutes for the air it was forced to cut
corners where it simply couldn't afford
to which means the deciding point has to
go to the anime the release the battle
of gods movie wasn't the wrong route
it was their only move it wasn't by
chance that the battle of gods movie was
the first continuation of the canon
since 1995 or ever with a movie the
truth is after almost two decades past
by Toei wasn't sure if the Japanese
public was still interested in
Dragonball the same way it was in the
early 90s and so they tested the
public's interest with this movie and in
reality it's thanks to the success of
battle of gods and resurrection of F
that we now have our old show back in
producing new content weekly and while I
know there are many of you out there who
resent Dragon Ball super and find it
boring or subpar
I can't change your mind but I will say
this the first saga of Dragon Ball Z had
39 episodes and I got us to this point
this is what happened on the 39th
episode of Dragon Ball super it's still
such a young show and has so much yet to
offer but I'd love to hear what you guys
think do you agree disagree let me know
in the comment section down below if you
guys want to see more Dragon Ball
content like this please feel free to
subscribe I'm totally not Marc
I'll until we meet again guys thank you
so much for watching